A travel bubble between New Zealand and Australia will kick off next week.
New Zealand's Prime Minister Jacinda Ardern told reporters on Tuesday...
...that quarantine-free travel will begin on April 19th for the neighboring countries.
She said that conditions for the bubble had been met,...
...and will give economic recovery a boost.
New Zealand broadcaster 1 News...
...said that the bubble is expected to run on a state-by-state basis...
...and would restrict travelers from certain areas if there is an outbreak.
The two countries faced mounting pressure from businesses to reopen borders.
The plans for the bubble were previously shelved...
...after sporadic outbreaks in some Australian cities,...
...but both countries have managed the pandemic...
...better than other developed nations...
...after closing their international borders to non-citizens...
...relatively early during the health crisis.
Australia has just over 900 deaths,...
...and New Zealand recorded 24 deaths from COVID-19.